hi I'm Eric Voss and among the many
great trailers we saw at comic-con was
this very interesting trailer for ready
player one film coming out in March 2018
directed by Steven Spielberg from a book
by Ernest Cline and even if you aren't
familiar with the book you're probably
like what the hell is the Iron Giant
doing in this movie so I'm going to
explain what ready player one is
background on the book and why this
movie is insanely perfect for what we do
here at new rockstars and of course
because ready player one is a story
about pop culture references and easter
eggs I'm going to point out every single
Easter egg in this trailer guys there
are an insane amount and I think we
caught them stuff that no one else did
so let's get started are you ready I
live here in Columbus Ohio and 20 45 it
still ranked the fastest growing city on
earth but sure doesn't seem like it when
you live in the stacks okay so this
trailer opens with a voice of Wade Watts
narrating the whole set up so to fill
you in on this in the book ready player
one it's set in the Year 2044 dystopian
future where fossil fuels have been
depleted and global warming is set in
making the world this overcrowded
junkyard where people have to live in
these stacks these crappy trailers that
are piled on top of each other but
people escape that world inside the
online virtual reality universe called
the Oasis it was created by a guy named
James Halliday who before he died
announced in his will that he hid an
easter egg somewhere in this universe
and whoever finds it will inherit his
fortune and his whole corporation kind
of like Willy Wonka did with his golden
ticket by the way maybe not the smartest
way to ensure the future of your company
anyway the hero of this story is Wade
watts he's obsessed with Halliday he
reads his personal journal that's called
interact Almanac and he has made it his
mission in life to learn all the 80s pop
culture that Halliday designed the Oasis
around so that you can find this egg
Wade is a Gunther that's a term for egg
hunter also the name of a German foreign
exchange student Gunther who believed me
at summer camp I never forget you
Gunther and in the Oasis he goes under
the Avatar name of parts of all by the
way the name parts of all is a reference
to the character Percival the Welshman
from the legend King Arthur first of all
lives deep in the woods and has never
even seen a knight or a sword or a horse
but it's that innocence that leads him
to
finding the Holy Grail Ernest
client-based Wade storyline on this
character and looking at these opening
shots we get a sense of how Spielberg is
adapting this world of ready player one
the stacks look exactly like they do on
the cover of Klein's book I also like
the details of the drones buzzing around
and notice that despite this world
looking like something out of wall-e
each home has a satellite dish and
several of them have wind turbines so
these small details are giving us a
sense of how lived in this world is and
specifically how Internet connectivity
is really the only thing that matters
also with the fuel shortage alternative
energy sources like wind are really
essential now the next part shows us a
lot more Easter eggs so let's move on
they called our generation than missing
millions missing not because we went
anywhere there's nowhere left to go
nowhere except the Oasis
okay so here we see Wade entering his
hideout now way normally lives with his
aunt because his mother died from a meth
overdose and then it really only took
him in so that she could have more food
ration so he doesn't really get along
with her so we spent all this time here
inside this old van now remember Wade is
obsessed with 80s nostalgia from
studying holidays interest so Easter
eggs are everywhere here you can
actually see a lot more of them in a
promo shot published by Entertainment
Weekly before Comic Con but in this
trailer you can definitely see Garbage
Pail Kids stickers on the wall and real
life those are super rare and extremely
valuable now also notice how he keeps
his VR headset on a Commodore 64
joystick commodore 64 was an early 80s
gaming system and on the shelf behind
that there are these Qbert stickers now
in his voiceover Wade says that his
generation is called the missing
millions because they all plug in and
escape into this virtual world this is a
reference to the term lost generation it
was coined by Gertrude Stein and
popularized by Ernest Hemingway in the
1920s it referred to the generation that
came of age during World War one many
young men died in that war and the ones
who survived had the sense of
aimlessness and confusion to them but it
also produced some of the best creative
work in American history writers like
Hemmingway and Stein but also F scott
Fitzgerald II Cummings and tons of
others so the missing millions is Ernest
Cline's version of that this generation
of aimless
youth in a world falling apart looking
to escape inside their own imagination
and speaking of imagination the music
here is a cover of pure imagination from
Willy Wonka and the Chocolate Factory
[Music]
I'm with me Angela you know world your
imagination obviously it's an
appropriate lyric for Wade entering
literally this world of pure imagination
but also the movie Willy Wonka and Roald
Dahl's book as I mention before is a
clear inspiration for ready player one
with the mysterious holidays Easter egg
hunt obviously based on Willy Wonka's
golden ticket search actually Steven
Spielberg reportedly looked into getting
Gene Wilder to play Halliday but Wilder
had retired from acting and has since
passed away now the character is being
played by Mark Rylance who Spielberg
worked with on bridge of spies and the
big guy honestly you can't tell me
that's not what the movies called let's
move on the only place that feels like a
meaning
a world where the limits of reality or
your own imagination okay lot going on
here this looks like a scene from the
books that set in a place called the
distracted globe
that's a nightclub owned by a guy named
Ogden Moro also known as AAG he is the
co-creator of the Oasis and he's played
by Simon Pegg actually his and
Halliday's relationship is based on the
relationship between Steve Wozniak and
Steve Jobs
now jobs like Halliday was credited as
this genius visionary behind Apple and
he's now immortalized after his death
whereas Wozniak kind of like OGG is the
underappreciated engineer who actually
built the technology that it was based
on and yes this scene is filled with
Easter Egg cameos first parts of all
passes Harley Quinn and Deathstroke from
the DC comic universe and according to
klein all the guests here are people
that we would recognize
I spotted Conan the Barbarian over there
on the left and it could be wrong but
very far on the right in the bag though
look a lot like shrek Sears shook his
love struck his life and then Gandalf
from Lord of the Rings can be spotted
dancing in the air actually the spinning
in the air is exactly how the dancing in
this party scene is described in the
book read let's move on
[Music]
[Music]
we these Easter eggs keep coming first
there's the Iron Giant so in the books
there is a battle featuring Ultraman now
Ultraman is the classic 60s Japanese TV
show with giant fighting robots actually
inspired things like Power Rangers are
really the Super Sentai series that high
Ranger is dubbed over also Pacific Rim
but it sounds like this movie is
swapping out Ultraman with the Iron
Giant also we see some other characters
in this theme and according to Kline
those are Dido and showed us how the
books tattoo and shadow are Japanese
Gunter's Gunther
they rival weight and work as a team as
they search for the egg but look at this
structure in the background this looks
like the temple of drinks this is
featured in the lyrics and the cover art
for an album by the band rush 2112 and
it won't spoil it but the lyrics of this
album do feature heavily in the plot for
ready player one that also might be the
second half of this trailer features
another song by Rush Tom Sawyer and then
I like how right after we get this title
slide with Steven Spielberg we see the
DeLorean time machine from Back to the
Future now Steven Spielberg
executive-produced Back to the Future
so yes the öberg is directing a movie
that's kind of a love letter to his own
work actually have some more thoughts on
that later this DeLorean by the way is
drifting around the Bethesda Fountain in
New York's Central Park then we see cows
now joust is the 80s arcade game where
you fight these warrior ostriches and I
love the way it looks here especially
how they turn into an egg when they get
destroyed just like they do in the game
actually in the book part of all winning
a game of joust plays a critical role in
the story and yeah in this shot he's
riding a mecha scorpion which some
people say could be a reference to the
Scorpion from the game centipede let's
move on
okay so here we see H and action age is
way best friend in the Oasis and a
fellow Gunther Gunther H is also an
amazing combatant now minor spoiler here
about H as a character if you don't
really want to know what you can skip at
a time but these filmmakers themselves
already announced this that H will be
played by Lee no ways for a master of
none so yes
H is actually a female by the name of
Helen Harris that's why her avatars name
is pronounced as H and this whole idea
of using avatars to represent yourself
however you want is a big theme Burnitz
Kline actually he was inspired largely
by the movie The Matrix and the company
that made that movie Village Roadshow is
also making this movie fun fact in the
original script of The Matrix the
character switch was originally going to
be a man in the real world who then
switches to become a female in the
matrix and yeah there are more cool
Easter eggs here H is using an assault
rifle from Halo to shoot Freddy Krueger
while duke nukem fires a rocket and then
I like how H reaches a hand out to
collect the coins that Freddy Krueger
turns into when he dies and if you look
over here on the left side of the frame
this figure looks like katana for mortal
combat let's move on
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
besides he's done for me
okay so here we meet the Sixers so in
ready player one there's a big
corporation called ioi innovative online
industries and it's run by Nolan Sorento
he's played by ben mendelsohn from rogue
one and he actually shows up briefly
later in this trailer so Sorento and his
company want to take over the Oasis and
monetize it by winning holidays egg
hunts so he hires all these operatives
to compete in the games for him they're
called Sixers for the six-digit employee
numbers that all begin with six and in
the shot notice the words on the news
ticker when the copper key so to find
holidays egg you have to first acquire
three keys the copper key the Jade key
and the crystal key now this race isn't
in the book weight actually gets the
copper key in a different way but
getting the copper key is a big moment
it makes them famous and everyone
realizes that Halladay's egg hunt isn't
just a myth it's a real thing and yes
this background is also filled with a
ton of Easter eggs let's do a quick
rundown there's the van from the 18 the
80s TV series also over on the right
there is lore across from the Tomb
Raider games and dizzy Wallen from Gears
of War they're chatting and then next to
them there's the killer car the Plymouth
Fury from Stephen King's Christine and
then over on the left this looks like
the pole position car from the Atari
game and a couple shots later you can
see Ryu from Street Fighter walking
between the cars now Ernst Klein claims
that the Batmobile is somewhere in the
background here I couldn't see it but
I'm thinking that yeah as the writer the
movie he's seen different shots so
somewhere we're going to see the
Batmobile show up in this race we
actually see even more cars appear in
the next section
Oh
okay so there is lots of cool stuff here
age is driving Bigfoot a monster truck
but then check out the car that it cuts
through this hood has a QR code on it
there's actually a different QR code in
the entertainment weekly' promo shot
that didn't lead to anything but this
one does you scan it it translates to
the URL join the quest I oh that takes
you to a website for innovative online
industries it's cool and not too
exciting on its own but then when you
click on that Twitter link it takes you
to a Twitter page for a ready player one
movie but then click on that website
ready player one movie com and it plays
a slightly different kind of the trailer
but right before it does there's a split
second animation of this scoreboard ok
this scoreboard is a big deal for the
book it shows where each person is with
their point total and if you're at the
top of it you're pretty much a celebrity
now here we don't see the names on it
but if you freeze it at just the right
frame you can see numbers on it but you
can decode these numbers and translate
them to letters and all of these numbers
become names of characters in the movie
which is really cool but the big
implication of it is the fact that they
put this in the trailer tells us that
there are probably other mysterious
codes hidden in the trailer as well in
fact you've already seen one of them in
the clips that we've looked at so far
but there's more to it in the rest of
the trailer so I'll talk about it at the
end okay so looking at the other
vehicles here we see this bike which is
Canada's bike from the anime film Akira
we actually get a better shot of it
later but behind it is the Ford Falcon
interceptor from Mad Max and behind that
is KITT from Knight Rider I also like
the detail of the Statue of Liberty in
the background now it's totally in the
wrong place in real life it's on Liberty
Island not in the middle of the city but
this is kind of like when video games
recreate real-world locations placing
famous landmarks wherever they're most
visually prominent not necessarily
accurate or maybe it's another 80s
reference to when the magician David
Copperfield made the Statue of Liberty
disappear maybe not but you can also see
the DeLorean time machine again passing
the camera right behind the Canadian
bank and then again as all the cars go
over this Hot Wheels style jumped in as
the kanita bike skids the camera whips
around and if you freak to the right
second you can make out this car in the
background this is the Griswold family
car from the national lampoon's vacation
movie and yeah here we get a better look
at the bike and it
as an Atari logo on the front but also a
Sega logo and Hello Kitty sticker and a
logo for the Japanese game developer
title so the driver of this bike is
another character named Artemis Artemis
spelled with a three because it's cool
she's a famous Gunther and a blogger
Gunther and yeah she's named after
Artemis the Greek goddess of the hunt
Wade actually has a huge crush on her in
the books but I don't want to spoil here
where that goes let's move on to the
final section
[Music]
okay so here we start off with a closer
look at the DeLorean which switches from
hover mode to Street mode as it avoids
these awesome wrecking balls and the
interior is laid out just like it is in
Back to the Future there's a time
circuit board on the dash notice how the
bottom date is the last time departed
which is November 12 1955 which in Back
to the Future is a day that Marty
travelled back in time to the top line
is the destination time which is October
26 1985 which is the year in Marty's
present that he's trying to get back to
meanwhile the middle line is the present
time which has been changed for this
movie to be February 11 2014 5 also
liked how instead of the license plate
reading out a time like it is back to
the future it changed it in this movie
two parts of all his username I also
like the detail of the Mad Max
interceptor flipping over and over again
just like it does in road warrior now
when Wade takes off his OSS visor you
can see for a second a reflection of
Nolan's Sorento I'm thinking this is a
key moment from the book and again I
don't want to spoil it here but the
final shot of this trailer is the
crystal key now again this is the final
key that unlocks holidays egg but notice
the AAA on it I'm guessing that's for
Alcoholics Anonymous no enter hex
Almanac remember how a personal journal
that Wade analyzes so obsessively but
actually let's go back to look at that
ready player one title I may have
noticed that in this trailer Spielberg
is using a lot of lens flares some
people are saying he's borrowing JJ
Abrams signature director move which is
pretty ironic because Abrams as a
director is basically modeling his
visual style on Steven Spielberg's nappy
paws at the right moment letters start
to appear on the screen they also appear
on 2018 and every other time a title has
appeared on screen so the sequence
people have found so far is QQ s q QQ r
t vs q cube there may have been others
but that's ones we found so this is more
Arg code sometimes in trailers and games
the makers will hide little letters and
numbers and like bursts of audio which
when you filter them through various
coding programs they've
eventually produce phrases and website
URLs sometimes coordinates or more
images so at this moment people online
are still trying to figure out exactly
what these letters could mean it's
honestly above my pay grade but if you
have figured it out let me know now a
final word about ready player one I'm
very excited for this movie the whole
concept of virtual reality hunters
scouring pop culture for hidden easter
eggs is a full fantasy adaptation of the
kind of stuff we do here at new rock
stars it's some how I've tried to
describe my job on tinder no luck so far
and if you made any additional
breakthroughs yeah again tweet me at EA
boss or at new rock stars at new rock
stars also please share this video to
get everyone else in on this massive
Easter egg hunt and subscribe to new
rockstars and you can help us make more
videos by contributing to us on patreon
big thanks to all of our current donor
thank you all for watching and let me
know if you found the easter eggs we hid
in this breakdown just getting there
aren't any or are there